une équipe en deuxième division une
autre en division d'honneur et la
dernière en promotion de ligue
trois équipes trois niveaux seniors qui
permettent aux plus jeunes d'imaginer
l'avenir
mercredi dernier la fédération française
de football décerné pour la deuxième
année consécutive un label d'excellence
à l'école de foot féminin de montigny le
bretonneux le label représente la
récompense justement d'un d'un club
structuré parce qu'on a un bon accueil
on fait une bonne formation avec des
éducatrices diplômées
et enfin en forme des jeunes on a le
nombre suffisant on est tous kichwa le
label récompense l'encadrement les
installations et équipements et
soulignent le gage de sérieux d'une
école un sérieux qui a porté ses fruits
puisque certaines joueuses ont déjà
participé à des stages ou des
compétitions en équipe de france au club
certaines parmi les plus jeunes voient
déjà l'avenir en grand professionnel à
lyon ou quatre rangées en amérique dans
les yvelines
montigny le bretonneux fait figure
d'exception c'est la seule équipe à
posséder ce label avec celle de paris
saint germain qui sera labellisée à son
tour pour la seconde fois jeudi prochain